[Music]
to be honest i think we were quite
apprehensive before joining i mean it's
a two-week sprint and we
weren't sure whether or not we could
meet the timelines or even get the value
that we thought was required
out of it so we were quite intimidated i
came in with
curiosity and on how actually design can
help to refine and make a difference in
my business within the industry
but actually through the process which
was intense
we found it incredibly helpful from
multiple dimensions
it gave us so much to think about in
terms of our organization
so we found it incredibly valuable for
both our existing work streams
but also in terms of provoking new
thought about what we could bring to the
table
this bbod program is really helpful
to us because it lets us understand the
importance of the
design within the business as well as
implementing
this design in the business process
itself
so i think this reviewing process right
is very critical
because it helps you to think out of the
box
it also helps you to eliminate some of
the things that might not be
crucial might not be useful we can use
the same practices that we use in
developing our own products
into our processes into a business and
making it better
as designers we're using these practices
a lot but we never
apply it in other things because we kind
of think of it as other side
it's not just marketing it's not just
aesthetics it's not just creative
it plays a part in how we do personas
how we do profiling how
we can design our products and services
to cater for
the needs of our current customers and
as well as our future consumers
the program of allowing me to do is to
deepen
my understanding especially when it
comes to the focus
and the importance of really integrating
the voice of our guests inside of our
experiences
you know as being an artist a designer
and a creative leader
but really really seizing the importance
to also
bring the analytical uh element to it so
the sort of analytical leadership
is also something that was a very very
big insight for me
how granular that top quartile
performers
implemented steps and approaches to
define
very customer-centric approaches to
doing business and evolving their
business
the importance of cross-functional teams
not only in terms of of course you know
bringing together teams you know coming
from different backgrounds
but really bringing them with the very
specific intention
of solving problems i thought that was a
really really nice nugget
i thought it was a truly valuable
for me and the rest of the team when you
take a look
at a project or a business initiative
with user perspective and the different
stakeholder perspectives
it transforms the way you shape it and
it transforms the way
you measure it so that was a very clear
outcome for us